bro this is it poor all might is moments
away from being gojoed stain is staining
the walls of a building Hercules has
been reduced to scrap metal and all for
one is seconds away from reaching
shigaraki this was an emotional chapter
that kept urging all might to keep
fighting and to survive but how does he
come back from this all might is
severely injured he will never be the
same so can he really survive this is
all for one about to reach higaraki and
complete his master plan in the very
next chapter we need to talk about this
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy our imagery content and you want
us to keep it going leave a quick like
and comment right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help us
awaken the true power of our Quirk here
on the channel by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a big favor and
subscribe right now subscribing is of
course completely free and every single
subscription matters
finally this video will contain mha
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter the fight between all
might and all for one reached a new
phase and then a massive twist
completely changed the game on the
battlefield after all might use an
extremely powerful laser attack to do
immense damage to all four months body
all of One became even younger as he was
forced to regenerate over and over again
the villain is now barely older than a
toddler but he still has his Quirk and
he still has the intelligence of an
adult all for one clearly doesn't have
too much time left but he still
possesses a massive threat for all might
and the other Heroes the villain
eventually breaks free of all might
laser and he prepares to take the hero
out once and for all at this point all
mine is already severely injured he's
barely able to stand and saw a single
attack from all for one will probably
kill him right now however that's when
the big twist happened just as
all-for-one is about to kill all might
he suddenly realizes that he can't move
he's paralyzed that's because the hero
killer stain has finally joined the
fight and he used his Quirk to lick some
of the blood that all for one left
behind on the ruins of the battlefield
thanks to the effects of stain's Quirk
all for one is now unable to move and
all mine and stain have a chance to
defeat him together the newest chapter
shows us the lead up to how stain
arrived on the battlefield and managed
to take all for one by surprise he had
figured out what was going on due to the
convo that happened between all might in
genium and Todoroki earlier and he used
his epic cyberpunk glider to follow the
trail of blood and debris until he found
the exact location of all might and over
one's fight naturally he saw a lot of
blood on the battlefield and at first he
wasn't sure which one was the hero's
blood and which one was the villain's
blood but since he met all my incomingo
he knew what all might smelled like so
he was able to determine which blood was
over once honestly given the fact that
stain doesn't even look like he has a
nose his sense of smell is impressive
and so stain was able to use his Quirk
blood curdle to paralyze all for one
back in the present moment stain is
wondering if all mine has finally
understood the meaning of his own
existence state has always deeply
admired almight a man whom he considers
to be the prime example of a true hero
and stain wants all might to Value his
own life and to struggle against death
stain wants the hero to do these things
because like many of us stain feels that
all might is preparing to sacrifice his
own life for the Next Generation stain
is worried that almight has already
given up on life and he's just waiting
to die a noble death in order to pave
the way for the new generation almight
says that he does understand where stain
is coming from and the two men decide to
team up they both launch an attack on on
all for one however the villain is
prepared and even though he is paralyzed
he is still able to use a combination of
two quirks forced activation and
Phlebotomy this allows the villain to
eject all of his blood from his own body
and we see the blood splashing wildly
all over the battlefield ever since
stain decided to leave Tartarus on his
own without pledging allegiance to the
villains all for one anticipated that he
might become a problem and so he
prepared a plan just for such a
situation again you really have to give
it to all for one he is a master planner
he doesn't foolishly underestimate his
opponents and he tries to anticipate and
work around every potential problem not
only did all for one essentially replace
the blood inside his own body in order
to negate the effects of stain's Quirk
he also used anti-gen modification to
change his blood's composition this
means that the blood inside his body is
now different from what it was before
and so stains attempts to use all for
one's old blood to paralyze him again
will be futile apparently this ability
to change his own genetic makeup is what
helped over one avoid capture but the
authorities for generations and of
course he has no problem using it again
against stain the villain then activates
another Quirk that sends a grotesque
gigantic mouth flying from his back and
it bites right into stain in fact it
traps stain inside its massive Jaws
stain is clearly injured by the teeth of
the giant mouth and are concerned all
might screams out stain's name the
villain then uses that giant mouth to
throw stain violently and the hero
killer flies through a bunch of
buildings before finally coming to a
stop several city blocks away as a
concerned all might looks on the villain
flies off to the place where Stane had
landed in order to steal his Quirk
almight uses the last of his strength to
fly towards stain in an attempt to save
him and all for one uses the time he has
as before the hero arrives to use some
good old-fashioned talk no Jutsu on
stain he tells Stein that he was an
important figure in the growth and
development of tomuro shigaraki and the
league of villains but his role in the
story ended there honestly I wish over
one wasn't right when he said this but
unfortunately horikoshi did kind of
completely sideline stain after that and
if we're being honest he's never been
truly relevant since then it's really
unfortunate because stain was one of my
favorite characters in the early stages
of the series and I do think that he had
a lot more potential to develop and grow
into an excellent dark and gritty
character but even though the villain's
words kind of bothered me personally
because he's not exactly wrong stain
isn't bothered by these words he says
that his role isn't over yet because
they are all part of one big process
long ago all my taught staying the true
meaning of being a hero stay Bane then
proceeds to raise his hands as if giving
aside to almight to win this battle and
to keep living it seems that stain has
come to realize what all might has
already realized and what horikoshi is
really trying to emphasize in this final
Arc a true hero is not any single hero
at all true heroism requires all the
heroes to work together towards the same
Noble goal just like Deku and the
current generation of hero students has
been learning in the past few arcs stain
knows that he is part of that process
too and he knows that the other true
heroes like Deku are out there and ready
to take the torch of true heroism from
the older generation a smiling all for
one then proceeds to punch stain into
the building but before the villain can
turn his attention to all might Hercules
once again shows up to help the hero
even though all might thought that every
part of Hercules was already destroyed I
guess there were still a couple of
pieces left and these pieces also tell
all might that he has to live before
they too are blasted into Oblivion by
one of all for one's attacks
however thanks to these parts standing
between all for one's attack and all
might the hero survives the attack but
even though Mike is still alive his
armor is now completely destroyed and
what's worse his right arm was seemingly
blown apart by the villain's attack as a
barely conscious and brutally injured
all might lies on the ground now
completely armorless and gadgetless he
sees a vision of Nana shimura standing
over him and telling him to get up he
also sees sir night eye standing over
him and he realizes that these are just
illusions that he's seeing his own body
and mind are trying desperately to
muster up one last effort they are
trying desperately to motivate all might
to get up one more time all might has no
more support items his arm is gone he
can't even use his legs properly but he
still refuses to give up he begins
crawling with that one remaining arm and
he calls out to the villain screaming
I'm Not Dead Yet come over here
in that moment almight's face looks
absolutely haunting he is a bloody wreck
he looks like he could die at any moment
and yet his eyes are still sharp and he
is still smiling he looks absolutely
insane like he's about to tell us that
we live in a society and then on the
final page of the chapter we see the UA
building falling from the sky in the
distance
unfortunately even though the UA is
still some distance away all for one is
now close enough to use that sludge
teleportation Quirk that Johnny the
normal possessed to teleport right to
the UA despite all might's best efforts
it looks like the villain succeeded in
the end he made it to the site of the
epic battle between Deku and shigaraki
he reached shigaraki or at least he
almost did but he's not quite there yet
as all for one looks towards the falling
UA building and as all might screams at
him from below to come and fight him him
this chapter comes to an end wow this
was another intense chapter and there
were some really good moments here and
also some disappointing ones at least
for me personally I like the fact that
all for one once again showed that he is
a master planner who anticipates every
possible scenario and I really liked how
all might continues to surpass his
limits and Fight Against All Odds all
might truly is an epic character and a
legendary hero that said I didn't like
how easily stained was dispatched by All
For One the villain's words about
stain's role in the story ending after
he was sent to Tartarus hit hard for me
personally because I always thought that
sidelining stain was a missed
opportunity and now Apparently after all
that anticipation for stain to join the
fight he was easily defeated by All For
One within the span of like a single
chapter I don't know maybe stain will
get up and keep fighting but as things
stand right now it looks like he was
absolutely wrecked by all for one in
record time and honestly a great
character like stain deserves better
especially if this turns out to be his
final fight in the entire series are you
guys disappointed about what happened
with stain in this chapter let me know
down below okay now about all might how
in the world is he going to recover from
this he can't walk he lost an arm he
lost all his armor and support items and
yet he is still trying to challenge all
for one to fight him in the hopes of
distracting the villain long enough for
him to remind himself out of existence
before he reaches the UA at this point
the only way all might can succeed is if
someone comes and helps him again or if
all for one's time just runs out
suddenly like right now the only other
possibility is that all might will
finally die at the hands of all for one
in the very next chapter and even though
that's not impossible it would be pretty
strange for that to happen after this
entire chapter went out of its way to
tell all might over and over again and
that he can't give up on life and that
he has to live I don't know about you
guys but now I really don't know what is
going to happen next I was convinced
that all might would die in this fight
and that he would sacrifice himself for
the Next Generation but after the events
of this chapter we can't be sure because
everyone kept telling Almighty that he
has to live and that he has to keep
fighting but how how does all might
survive being in such a terrible
situation I want to see your theories
let me know down in the comments below
what will happen next will all might die
or survive will all for one get to
shigaraki or will his time run out how
will this battle between the greatest
hero and the greatest villain of the
previous generation affect the battle
between Deku and shigaraki the greatest
hero and villain of this generation I
can't wait to find out and another thing
that I can't wait to find out is the
truth about deku's Dad because horikoshi
has been telling us that we're gonna
learn about deku's Dad before the series
ends and yet the series is almost ended
and we still don't know anything if you
want to check out some crazy theories
about who deku's dad might be don't miss
my video about deku's Dad link on screen
and in the description if you enjoyed
this mha video and you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment right now and if you want to
help us awaken this Channel's Quirk by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
big favor and subscribe right now